>>> HAPPY WEEK 12, EVERYBODY AND
WELCOME TO THE B.R. BETTING
"SQUAD RIDE" PRESENTED BY DRAFT
KINGS.
I HOPE YOU-ALL HAD A GOOD
THANKSGIVING AND FOLLOWED GREG
AND I'S PARLAY BECAUSE WE CASHED
FOR THE BILL'S MAFIA.
FEELING GOOD, FEELING GOOD.
I'M CONNER ROGERS, IT'S
BASICALLY HIS TIME OF THE YEAR,
THE HOLIDAY SEASON, THE GIVING
SEASON.
GREG IVORY.
HOW WE FEELING TODAY?
>> CONNER, FEELING VERY
GENEROUS.
FEELING GENEROUS.
IT'S NOT DECEMBER, IT'S STILL
NOVEMBER BUT WE'RE STILL GIVING
AWAY HOODIES.
I'M ACTUALLY IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT'S NEW TO THE
SHOW, IF YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW,
NOW YOU KNOW.
THIS RIGHT HERE IS THE HANDY
DANDY IPAD.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET YOUR HOODIES
AND JERSEYS AND PROBABLY CAN GET
SOME MONEY.
I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET TAPPED IN.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW,
CONNER.
I SEE GOAT GARDEN SAYS MICHAEL
PITMAN EQUALS GO SHOUTOUT TO
YOU.
LONNIE HAWKMAN SAYS RAIDERS ARE
GOING TO KILL IT.
YEAH, SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNER, LET'S GET THIS THING
GOING.
>> YEAH, LET'S GET IT ROLLING.
YOU KNOW THE DRILL BY NOW.
THIS IS THE SHOW WE BET ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR THE LOCK OF
THE WEEK OF WHO IS GETTING IN
THE END ZONE.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL.
WHO IS IT GOING TO BE?
THESE ARE YOUR TOP PICKS OF THE
WEEK.
JONATHAN TAYLOR AT THE TOP.
NO SURPRISE.
HE SCORES LITERALLY EVERY WEEK.
HARRIS AND D.BO SAMUEL BEHIND
HIM BOTH FANTASY SUPER STARS AND
MIKE EVANS LOOKING TO GET IT
DONE AGAINST THE COLTS.
KYLE PITS AGAINST JACKSONVILLE
AND MAYBE THE OFFENSE GETS ON
TRACK AND JALEN HURTS AGAINST
THE GIANTS IS ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS IN FANTASY ALL AROUND
AND ODELL BECKHAM JUNIOR COMING
IN AT PLUS 225, SO INTERESTING
BOARD TODAY.
SOME NEW NAMES AND AS ALWAYS,
PLENTY TO GIVE AWAY.
GREG, I KNOW YOU GOT THE HOODIES
BUT WHAT ELSE YOU GOT IN STORE?
>> I'M NOT ONLY GIVING AWAY
HOODIES BUT NOT ONE, BUT TWO NFL
JERSEYS.
ONE TO THE WINNING LOCK LEGEND
AND ONE TO A LUCKY COMMENTER
LIKE YOURSELF.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND DO WHAT
YOU GUYS DO.
FILL THEM UP.
I NEED EMOJIS.
I NEED GIFTS.
I NEED SUNSETS.
I NEED CONNER IS THE BEST.
I NEED #WINNERSONLY PLEASE.
FILL THOSE COMMENTS UP.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, CONNER, MOST
IMPORTANTLY, WE NEED WINNERS
ONLY PLEASE.
WE NEED WINNERS ON PLEASE.
MAKE SURE Y'ALL FILL THE
COMMENTS UP WITH WINNERS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU.
WE NEED ONE OF THESE TO BE THE
WINNER AND GOING TO BE THE SQUAD
RIDE LEADER.
THEY GET THE TITLE.
THEY GET THE NFL JERSEY GIFT
CARD AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
BOOST THOSE ODDS.
WE'LL TRAIL IT AND MAKE SOME
MONEY.
LET'S GET THIS SHOW ON THE ROAD.
FIRST PITCH COMES FROM CHASE
HOWARD.
TELL US WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT ALL OUR PLAYERS HERE.
LET'S SEE WHICH ONE HITS.
MIKE EVANS.
>> MIKE EVANS COMING IN ON THE
SPIN THE BOTTLE LEGEND AND WE
GOT DECISION TIME.
IT IS THE FIRST MATCHUP OF THE
DAY.
COMING FROM CAMERON GRANT.
LET'S SEE THE PICK.
♪
>> THE TREAT LEGEND WITH HARRIS.
WE HAVE MIKE EVIDENCE VANLS WITH
PLUS MONEY AND NAJI HARRIS.
HE'S A BEAST.
HOW ARE THE PEOPLE FEELING ABOUT
THESE?
WHAT DO WE NEED FROM THEM?
>> LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE
FIRST.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH ONE
ARE WE RIDING?
MIKE EVANS AND THE BOTTLE SPIN
LEGEND OR GOING WITH THE TREAT
LEGEND CONNER CALLING IT THE
DEMON LEGEND IN HARRIS?
WE KNOW WHAT NAJI IS IN
PITTSBURGH.
HE IS THE WORKHORSE THERE IN
PITTSBURGH BUT CONNER, YOU KNOW
WHAT I LIKE.
I LIKE VALUE.
I LIKE PLUS MONEY, MY GUY MIKE
EVANS IS BALLING.
HE'S SCORED IN THE LAST FOUR
WEEKS TOM BRADY FEEDING HIM IN
THE END ZONE.
HE'S A BIG RED ZONE TARGET FOR
BRADY SITTING AT PLUS MONEY.
I THINK I WANT TO RECREATE IT.
>> YOU'RE ALL OVER IT.
SINCE THE ANTONIO BROWN INJURY,
MIKE EVANS IS A MONSTER IN THE
END ZONE.
TOM BRADY IS FEEDING THIS GUY.
MIKE EVANS GOT IT DONE YEAR
AFTER YEAR SINCE HE CAME IN THE
LEAGUE.
LOVE HARRIS.
THE THING THAT WORRIES ME,
THEY'RE SCORING IN LOW GAMES AND
RUN THE BALL A MILLION TIMES AND
NO GUARANTEE.
FOR MIKE EVANS WHERE AT THE
COMMENTS GOING?
>> CONNER, THE COMMENTS ALL OVER
MIKE EVANS, EVAN LOCK AND EMOJI.
ISAAC BOATMAN SAYING BOTTLE
SPINNERS.
I GOT MY BOY LARRY, HALL OF FAME
LARRY IN THE BUILDING.
HIS COMMENT WENT AWAY.
HE SAID HARRIS IS EASY MONEY.
BACK AND FORTH IN THE COMMENTS,
BACK AND FORTH IN THE COMMENTS
BUT GUESS WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DECISION.
MY BOY MATT DODGER HAS JUST --
HE JUST VERIFIED IT.
WE'RE RIDING WITH MIKE EVANS IN
THE BOTTLE SPIN LEGEND TO MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT ROUND.
ALSO, ALSO, CONNER, IF I SAID
YOUR NAME, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I WANT YOU GUYS TO KNOW THAT.
>> PRETTY GOOD DEAL.
FIRST ROUND BELONGS TO THE
BOTTLE SPIN CHASE HOWARD.
WE GOT TWO CHALLENGERS
REMAINING.
LET'S GO TO ROUND TWO.
THE NEXT PITCH FROM JAKE THE
SNAKE.
LET'S SEE THE CHOICE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT THE MIKE EVAN LOBSTER,
THE JALEN HURTS WINE BOTTLE.
AND THE ULTIMATE SELECTED.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL WHO IS DOING IT FOR US THIS
WEEK?
JALEN.
GOOD GIRL.
JALEN HURTS LOOKING TO FEAST ON
THE GIANTS TODAY.
WE GOT DOUBLE PLUS MONEY.
MIKE EVANS PLUS 105 AND JALEN
HURTS WHO HAS BEEN A FANTASY
MONSTER THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS
AND PLUS 20.
I THINK YOU CAN GET THAT SKY
HIGH.
WHAT DO WE GOT GOING ON?
IS THIS ENOUGH TO KNOCK OFF A
JUICY PICK?
>> LET ME KNOW IN THE COMMENTS
ARE WE ROCKING WITH MIKE EVANS
OR JALEN HURTS.
I SEE WINNERS ONLY IN THE
COMMENTS.
WINNERS ONLY IN THE COMMENTS.
WINNERS ONLY GANG IS IN THE
COMMENTS.
Y'ALL LET ME KNOW.
I'M KIND OF TORN TO BE HONEST.
I JUST WENT OVER WHY I LIKE
EVANS.
BRADY SCORED IN THE LAST FOUR
WEEKS BUT MY GUY JIALEN HURTS HD
A GOOD GAME.
HE WENT IN THE END ZONE RUSHING
THREE TIMES LAST WEEK.
I SEE THAT, CONTINUING THAT
TREND WHEN THEY GET IN THE FIVE
CLOSER TO THE GOAL LINE.
THE JALEN HURTS PACKAGE, THE
JALEN HURTS POWER RIGHT, POWER
LEFT, I THINK THAT THAT'S GOING
TO COME OUT.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH JALEN HURTS.
I LIKE JALEN HURTS.
WHAT ARE YOU ROCKING WITH,
CONNER?
>> THE PLUS 120 IS WHERE I'M
SITTING.
THE EAGLES BUILT AN OFFENSE TO
THE STRENGTH AND JALEN HURTS
KNOWS HE DOESN'T HAVE TO GO AND
THROW 250, 300, 350 YARDS BUT HE
CAN ADD ON 70.
HE CAN BE YOUR RED ZONE OFFENSE
LIKE YOU SAID, GREG, YOU'RE
WITHIN THE TEN, YOU'RE WITHIN
THE FIVE.
USE HIS POSSIBILIMOBILITY TO GE
END ZONE.
THE EAGLES ARE RELYING ON THAT
FOR POINTS RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE NOT RELYING ON THEIR
RUNNING BACKS AS MUCH AS MOST
TEAMS BECAUSE OF WHAT HE CAN DO.
I LIKE THE MIKE EVANS PICK.
I WOULDN'T BE MAD IF THAT MOVES
FORWARD BUT WITH JALEN HURTS,
IT'S HARD TO BET AGAINST HIM NOW
AND HARD TO EXPECT ANYTHING OUT
OF THE NEW YORK GIANTS TO EXPECT
HIM.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS GOING TO
TAKE IT FOR ROUND THREE?
>> CONNER, I'M IN THE COMMENTS
AND THEY GOT ME OVER HERE
SMILING.
WINNERS ONLY IS IN THE BUILDING,
CONNER.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW BUT
WINNERS ONLY IS IN THE BUILDING.
J.J. SNAIL, J.J. SNAIL SAYS
HURTS IS THE GUY THEY ONLY RUN
THE BALL AND HAVE NO RUNNING
BACKS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU J.J. SNAIL.
YOU WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
MIKE EVANS TWO TOUCHDOWNS, IT'S
A LOCK.
HE'S PULLING THE OLD CONNER
ROGERS PLAYBOOK WITH TWO
TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
HE'S -- THAT'S A BOLD BET.
WE'LL GET TO BOLD BETS IN A
MINUTE.
I GOT HURTS IS THE LOCH NESS
MONSTER.
ONE MORE, CONNER.
ONE MORE.
DA
DAKINGGAMS.
>> IT'S DONE.
>> THEREFORE YOUR BOY JALEN
HURTS IS MOVING ONTO THE NEXT
ROUND.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> OH, YEAH, BY THE WAY,
EVERYBODY I MENTIONED, SORRY,
CONNER, BUT EVERYBODY I
MENTIONED, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JAKE THE SNAKE TAKES ROUND TWO.
THAT IS JALEN HURTS AT PLUS 120.
HE'S WON MORE MATCHUP UNTIL
MAYBE, JUST MAYBE WE GOT A SQUAD
RIDE LEADER.
SO FINAL CONTENDER, WINNER TAKES
ALL.
A FAMILIAR FACE AND GOLDBERG TO
CLOSE THIS OUT.
>> WHAT'S UP, BLEACHER REPORT?
WITH IT BEING THE FIRST NIGHT OF
HANUKKAH, WE'LL USE OUR TRUSTED
DROID
DRO
DRADEL HERE.
IF IT LANDS OCHN SHIN WE'RE
PICKING TAYLOR, IF IT LANDS ON
NUN WE'RE PICKING CUP AND IF IT
LANDS ON HAY, WE'RE PICKING
JABCOBE MYERS.
WE'RE PICKING JONATHAN TAYLOR
THIS WEEK'S ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
J.T. AT MINUS 200.
A HAPPY HANUKKAH FOR ALL THOSE
WHO CELEBRATE THE HANUKKAH
LEGEND AND GOLDBERG COMING IN
THE CLUTCH HERE.
GREG, YOU KNOW WHAT THIS COMES
DOWN TO.
DO YOU WANT TO BE BOLD OR DO YOU
WANT TO GO WITH OLD FAITHFUL?
J.T. SCORES EVERY WEEK BUT MINUS
200, YEAH, NOT REALLY THAT
EXCITING TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
BUT YOU LIKE A SAFE BET.
WHO DOESN'T?
JALEN HURTS PLUS 120.
WE DON'T PICK PLUS MONEY ON THE
SHOW A LOT AND YOU FIND A WAY TO
GET IT THERE.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU CAN DO
WITH THIS ONE.
LET'S CLOSE THIS THING OUT.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> CONNER, BEFORE I GIVE MY
TAKE, I WANT EVERYBODY IN THE
COMMENTS TO LET ME KNOW HOW THEY
ARE FEELING, WHAT THEY WANT TO
RIDE WITH.
ARE WE RIDING WITH JONATHAN
TAYLOR OR GOING WITH JALEN
HURTS?
BUT I DON'T KNOW, MINUS 200.
JONATHAN CONNER SCORED IN THE
LAST WEEKS.
HE'S AN MVP CANDIDATE.
WE KNOW THAT HE IS THE ENGINE OF
THAT COLTS' OFFENSE.
HE'S THE ENGINE OF THE COLTS'
OFFENSE BUT JALEN HURTS IS
SITTING AT PLUS 120.
CONNER, YOU KNOW HOW I VALUE MY
PLUS MONEY.
I THINK I HEIMIGHT WANT TO LEAN
THAT WAY.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING OR
FEELING?
>> I WANT TO GO BOLD HERE.
IT COMES DOWN TO IT.
J.T. HAS BEEN SO GOOD THAT HE'S
STARTING TO PLAY HIS WAY OUT OF
THIS.
ONCE YOU GET INTO THE MINUS 200
RANGE, THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH YOU
CAN DO WITH THE ODDS.
JALEN HURTS IS UNDOUBTEDLY
RISKIER.
YOU'RE BETTING ON A QUARTERBACK
TO SCORE.
HE CAN DO IT.
PLUS 120.
LET'S GET IT BOOSTED UP.
CAN WE SWAY THE COMMENT SECTION
TO RIDE WITH US AGAIN?
WE DID IT EVERY WEEK.
THE HIT ON THE "SQUAD RIDE" IS
PHENOMENAL.
LET'S DO IT ONE MORE TIME.
>> LET'S SEE IF WE CAN DO IT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT J.T. FOR MVP 0 SAYS TAYLOR
LOCK OF THE WEEK.
YEAH, MINUS 200, BROTHER.
I THINK IT WAS A LOCK.
WE GOT BACK WOOD HERBI SERKS
SASA
SAYS IT.
SPORTS TAKE SAYS I THINK
JONATHAN TAYLOR WILL POP OFF
THIS WEEK.
HE'S BEEN POPPING OFF EVERY
WEEK.
GOOD TAKE RIGHT THERE.
J.T. IS A LOCK COMING OFF A 5 T
GAME.
NO WAY HE DOESN'T SCORE.
J.T. IS A LOCK.
WHY NOT?
TWO FOR J.T.
SHOUTOUT TO CHILLY BURGER.
I GOT MAX IN THE COMMENTS GOING
WITH HURTS.
IT'S BACK AND FORTH, CONNER.
THE NEXT ONE I'LL SAY WE RIDE
WITH.
DONE WITH THAT ONE?
>> DONE WITH THAT.
>> HERE WE GO.
I GOT THANK YOU FOR THE VIBES, I
GOT M GOGGMGOBLUE WITH THE VIBE.
THANK YOU.
ALBERT, ALBERT, HERE WE GO.
ALBERT 15 SAYS HURTS AGAINST THE
GIER
GIANTS, HE'S GETTING TWO
TUDDIES.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE AND CONNER, WE MADE A
DECISION.
>> IT'S A WRAP.
>> WE COME TO A CONCLUSION.
IT'S A WRAP.
WE'RE RIDING WITH JALEN HURTS
AND THE LEGEND IS WINNING BUT
JALEN HURTS, WE'RE RIDING WITH
YOU TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC TO
SHOW YOU GUYS WHAT WE DO HERE.
YOU GUYS SEE THAT IT'S PLUS 120.
POOF.
THERE IT IS.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS, WE'RE POOBOOSTING FROM P
120 TO PLUS 200.
CHECK B.R. BETTING SOCIAL FOR A
LINK TO THE ODDS.
WE'LL SHOW YOU THE SCREEN SHOTS.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND
CELEBRATIONS BUT WE WANT WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
WOO.
>> PLUS 200.
THAT IS THE BEST WE'VE SEEN SO
FAR.
LET'S GET IT DONE TODAY JALEN
HURTS.
AND SPEAKING OF DONE, WE ARE NOT
DONE.
WE GOT MORE HOODIES, WE GOT MORE
LOCKS.
GREG STILL HAS A JERSEY GIFT
CARD TO GIVE AWAY SO IF YOU'RE
NOT THE SQUAD RIDE LEADER, YOU
STILL GOT A CHANCE.
COMMUNITY COMMENT CONTEST TIME
AFTER THAT CRAZY PERFORMANCE
LAST WEEK FROM J.T. WHERE HE
BASICALLY LIVED IN THE END ZONE.
HIS MVP ODDS HAVE MOVED UP TO
PLUS 1600.
NOW LET'S NOT FORGET RUNNING
BACK IS NOT WON MVP SINCE ADRIAN
PETERSON IN 2012 SO IT'S BEEN
AWHILE.
THIS IS A QUARTERBACK AWARD AND
THAT'S WHY HE'S DOWN AT THE
BOTTOM THERE AND ALL THE GUYS
AHEAD OF HIM ARE QUARTERBACKS SO
YOU GOT THE ODDS FOR THIS WEEK
WE ASKED YOU IN THE BR METING
COMMUNITY.
WE PICKED THE FAVORITE TWO
COMMENTS TO SEE WHAT YOU THINK.
>> I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH IS
THE BETTER TAKE?
GIVING OUT A HOODIE TO WHOMEVER
YOU CHOOSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE FIRST
COMMENT FROM DOMODALE SAYS IF
THIS HAPPENS TO NFL BETTER BE
READY FOR MAJOR BACKLASH IGNORED
HENRY 2 K SEASON.
HE DIDN'T GET A SINGLE MVP VOTE
LAST YEAR.
THAT IS VERY, VERY, VERY
INTERESTING.
CONNER, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
THAT?
>> DOM, I FEEL YOU.
SHOULDN'T WE BE PUSHING FOR
BETTER?
YOU'RE NOT WRONG BUT IF THE
VOTERS FINALLY GET THIS THING
RIGHT AND START GIVING MORE LOVE
TO NON-QUARTERBACKS, THAT'S A
GOOD STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
SO YEAH, HENRY KIND OF GOT
JOBBED A LITTLE BIT, RIGHT?
GREATNESS DOES NOT GET
APPRECIATED BUT J.T. IF IT IS
APPRECIATED MORE FOR THE TEAM,
DOESN'T GET A TON OUT OF CARSON
WEN
WENTZ.
GREAT.
SO BE IT.
I UNDERSTAND THE DISAPPOINTMENT
BUT JONATHAN TAYLOR GETTING THE
MVP LOVE IS A GOOD THING FOR
THIS AWARD.
>> I AGREE.
I AGREE WITH THAT, CONNER.
LET'S MOVE ONTO THE NEXT COMMENT
FROM MIKE SAM 83.
SHOUTOUT TO MIKE SAM 83.
HE SAID HE SHOULD BE THAT FIVE
TD GAME WAS IMPRESSIVE, YES, IT
WAS VERY, VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
CONNER, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON MY
GUY MIKE SAMS TAKE RIGHT HERE?
>> I LOVE IT.
HE SHOULD BE GETTING MORE DREAD.
EVERY
-- CREDIT.
ESSENTIALLY A LAUGHER AT THAT
POINT.
EVERYBODY IS A LITTLE AFRAID OF
TOM BRADY GETTING ONE BEFORE HE
FINALLY RIDES OFF AND GOD KNOWS
WHEN.
KYLER MURRAY COMING BACK.
WE KNOW WHAT HE CAN DO.
I LOVE THIS COMMENT.
GOOD VIBES ALL AROUND ONE OF THE
BEST YOUNG OFFENSIVE PLAYERS IN
THE ENTIRE LEAGUE IN JONATHAN
TAYLOR.
>> YES, YES, YES, LET ME HOP
INTO THESE COMMENTS, CONNER.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS AND
SEE WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
MY GUY JUSTIN IS SPAMMING US.
PLEASE DO NOT SPAM US, JUSTIN.
I WILL GIVE YOU A HOODIE FOR
GOOD TAKES.
HERE WE GO.
WE GOT AB STEEL SAYS J.T. IS
LITERALLY THE GOAT HE HAS EVERY
RUNNING BACK RECORD RIGHT NOW,
YARDS, T.D.s, TOTAL YARDS OVER
COOPER CUP.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS THE GOAT?
SHOUTOUT TO YOU FOR YOUR TAKE.
YOU ARE IN THE COMMENTS GIVING
US GOOD TAKES.
I GOT ISAAC BOATMAN, ISAAC BO
BOATMAN, SHOUT YOU TO YOU.
LOCKS UNDER WATER, LOCKS UNDER
WATER SAYS MATTHEW STAFFORD, HE
LIKES MATTHEW STAFFORD.
>> HE'S BROKEN RIGHT NOW.
HE HAS ELBOW PROBLEMS AND BACK
PROBLEMS.
NOT SURE ON THAT ONE.
SORRY, GREG.
>> YEAH, I MEAN --
>> YOU'RE OUT.
I'M JUST GOING TO -- I AGREE.
THEY'RE IN THE DIVISION AS THE
NINERS.
I MEAN, YOU SEE WHAT WE DID TO
THEM A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
ANYWAY, I'M MAKING A DECISION
HERE.
I WANT TO GO WITH DOM ORDECH
DO.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> GRABBING THE HOOS DDIE.
WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
PLAYER PROPS.
IT TIME FOR PROP LOCK OR DROP
IT.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
WE PICKED A COUPLE PROPS THAT
STUCK OUT TO US IN THE SLATE
TODAY AND WE NEED YOU, OF
COURSE, WE NEED YOU "THE SQUAD"
TO HELP US WHAITH WHAT WE GOT
GOING ON.
A LOCK OR DROP?
GREG, LET THE PEOPLE KNOW.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, EVERYBODY.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
IF THESE PROPS ARE A LOCK OR
DROP THEM IMMEDIATELY.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES TO
WHOEVER CAN HELP US OUT.
LET'S CHECK OUT THE FIRST ONE.
MY GUY JONATHAN TAYLOR TO RUSH
OVER OR UNDER 80.5 YARDS.
HE HAD 32 CARRIES FOR 185 LAST
WEEK.
OR NO, WEEK 11 SCORED FIVE
TOUCHDOWNS LAST WEEK.
CAN HE CONTINUE THE MVP CALIBER
SEASON?
CONNER, WHAT'S YOUR TAKE OF
THIS?
DO YOU THINK HE CAN DO IT?
J.T., IS HE GOING TO GET 80.5?
>> THIS IS A TRAP, GREG.
OVER 100 YARDS.
HE'S GOING TO CATCH THE BALL
LIVE.
HE'S GOING TO GET THE RUSHING
YARDS.
THE BUCK'S DEFENSE IS GOOD
AGAINST THE RUN.
THEY DON'T ALLOW PEOPLE TO GO
SINGLE HANDEDLY.
NOT AFRAID TO SELL OUT AGAINST
THE RUN.
DONE IT MANY TIMES BEFORE.
THEY HAVE THE FRONT TO DO IT AND
SPEEDY LINEBACKERS.
I DON'T THINK J.T. GETS SHUT
DOWN TODAY.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
HE'S GOING TO GET HIS IN THE END
ZONE AND ALL PURPOSE YARDS.
I'M NOT ON THIS ONE.
HE HOOVERS BETWEEN 50 TO 75
RUSHES YARDS.
I THINK THE BUCKS DEFENSE IS TOO
GOOD.
I THINK THIS IS A TRAP BET.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> CONNER, LET ME SEE WHAT THE
PEOPLE THINK.
I SEE A LOT OF OGARS.
SEE, JUSTIN, WHEN YOU GIVE US A
GOOD TAKE, YOU GET A HOODIE.
HE SAID OVER, GREG.
DON'T HATE THE SPAM.
I GET NO LOVE.
BEEN FOLLOWING CONNER SINCE THE
STF DAYS.
>> MUCH LOVE.
MUCH LOVE.
>> TRYING TO GET YOUR ATTENTION.
LOVE THE TAKE, JUSTIN.
HERE WE GO.
ACTUALLY, THAT'S IT, CONNER.
THAT'S IT.
IF YOU GUYS ARE LOOKING IN THE
COMMENTS, WHICH EVERYBODY THAT'S
IN THE BRF IS, THEY SEE JUSTIN
TAYLOR IS FLOODING THE COMMENTS.
THE OVER, EVERYBODY SAYING THE
OVER.
LET'S MOVE ONTO THE NEXT PROP.
MACK JONES, THE GUY FOR NEW
ENGLAND.
MACK JONES TO THROW OVER OR
UNDER 230.5 YARDS.
HE'S BEEN PERFORMING HUGE FOR
THE PATRIOTS.
HOWEVER, ONLY THREW FOR 207 IN A
TOUCHDOWN LAST WEEK.
CAN HE PICK IT UP THIS WEEK AND
LEAD THE PATRIOTS TO VICTORY
OVER THE TITANS?
CONNER, DO YOU LIKE MACK JONES
THROWING OVER 230.5 YARDS TODAY?
>> GREG, I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'LL
LET HIM QUITE FRANKLY.
I THINK NEW ENGLAND IS GOING TO
RIDE TODAY.
I THINK THEY COVERED THE LINE
THAT OPENED UP AT 6.5 TENNESSEE
HAS SO MANY INJURIES.
NEW ENGLAND'S RUNNING BACKS ARE
BOTH GOING TO PLAY.
HARRIS AND STEVENSON, MACK IS
SUPER EFFICIENT.
HE'S DONE EVERYTHING THEY HAVE
ASKED OF HIM.
I THINK HE'LL HAVE A REALLY GOOD
DAY BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE'LL
BE ALLOWED TO THROW THE BALL 40
TIMES.
SO 230 ISN'T A BIG NUMBER BUT
WOULDN'T SHOCK ME IF MACK IS
HOVERING AROUND 210, 215 AND
SITS ON THE BALL, RUN, RUN, RUN.
THEY DOMINATE IN THE TRENCHES.
THIS IS A BELT THAT'S A TRAP.
THAT'S HOW THEY GET YOU.
I'M A GUY THAT WILL ROOT FOR
NOTHING TO HAPPEN AND GO WITH
THE UNDERS.
>> NO, I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT, CONNER.
NOT ONLY DO I LIKE THAT, THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS ARE
AGREEING WITH YOU.
I SEE A LOT OF UNDERS.
C 4 SH SAYS UNDER 230 THE
PATRIOTS WILL RUN IT ALL DAY.
TENNESSEE CAN'T STOP THE RUN.
>> BOOM.
>> THERE IT IS, CONNER.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE CONNER TO ME.
WAIT, HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
D.J. SAYS OVER FOR THE MACK
ATTACK THE TITANS HAVE A BETTER
RUN DEFENSE THAN PASS DEFENSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S VALID BUT
JUST BECAUSE OF THAT WE'LL SEND
HIM A HOODIE.
ONE MORE, CONNER.
ONE MORE.
RAM TACKLE SAYS 265 YARDS TODAY
WITH THREE TOUCHDOWNS BEST
ROOKIE IN THE CLOSE, BEST COACH
IN THE HISTORY OF SPORTS.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> I THINK MY GUY WATCHED
JA'MARR CHASE THIS YEAR BUT KEEP
IT MOVING.
>> LOVE THE TAKES.
>> THE TAKES ARE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT?
THE TAKES ARE GOOD.
MAY THE BETTING GOODS BE IN OUR
FAVOR.
BEFORE WE GET OUT OF HERE, THIS
IS WHERE YOU AND I HAVE FUN.
TIME FOR BOLDEST BETS.
YOU'VE BEEN SCORCHING HOT.
LET THE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WE NEED
BEFORE WE DROP OUR BETS.
>> GET IN THE COMMENTS AND GIVE
US A BOLD BET.
WE WANT A LONG SHOT.
WE WANT THE PLUS, PLUS, PLUS
MONEY.
ALSO, TELL US WHETHER YOU'RE
RIDING WITH ME OR CONNER.
CONNER, GIVE IT TO THE PEOPLE.
TELL THEM WHAT YOU GOT.
>> YEAH, IF ANYONE IS RIDING
WITH ME TODAY, THEY'RE INSANE.
THIS IS MY BIGGEST HAIL MARY OF
THE YEAR NOW.
PLUS 1504.
MICHAEL CARTER PUT ON I.R. FOR
THE JETS.
IT'S TIED.
JOHNSON SHOW IN THE BACKFIELD
AGAINST THE HOUSEHOUSTON TEXANS.
KYLE PITS AGAINST THE JAGUARS IS
GOING TO BE ATLANTA'S OFFENSE
TODAY WITH A BANGED UP PATTERSON
AND DEEBO SAMUEL IS A MONSTER.
HE'S THE GUY YOU FEEL THE MOST
GOOD ABOUT ON THE LIST.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING THIS WEEK ON
THE BOLDEST BETS?
>> CONNER, LET'S PULL UP THE
GRAPHIC.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC.
I'M GOING TO GET STRAIGHT TO IT.
THERE IT IS.
TOM BRADY TO THROW BASICALLY 300
YARDS AND MY BOY JONATHAN TAYLOR
HAD THE OVER RUSHING YARDS.
YOU SEE THERE.
I SEE THIS GAME BEING A GOOD
ONE.
I THINK BOTH OFFENSES WILL KIND
OF GET IN THE FLOW AND THERE IT
IS.
HOPEFULLY THIS IS NUMBER THREE
IN A ROW.
WE HIT TWO OF THEM IN A ROW AND
HOPEFULLY, THIS ONE WILL
CONTINUE.
SHOUTOUT TO MATT DODGER BY THE
WAY.
SHOUTOUT TO MATT DODGER.
HE'S A LEGEND.
>> GREG LOOKING FOR THE HAT
TRICK THIS WEEK ON BOLDEST BETS.
FIRST TIME ON "THE SQUAD RIDE."
I'M FEELING IT.
WE NEED THE PEOPLE TO PICK WHO
THEY ARE RIDING WITH AND GET RID
OF THE NFL JERSEY BEFORE WE SIGN
OFF FOR WEEK NUMBER 12.
>> YES, SIR.
I GOT JESSIE 24 GET GREG
VERIFIED.
YEAH.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> MAKE THAT HAPPEN, BLEACHER
REPORT.
GOT TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
THAT DESERVES A JERSEY FROM ME.
YOU'RE GETTING A JERSEY BECAUSE
THAT'S A FACT.
HERE WE GO.
GOT TO GIVE AWAY SOME MORE
HOODIES.
I SEE BEAU SAYS BOTH OF US.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU BEAU GARDEN.
HERE WE GO, DAVANTE ADAMS HAVE
TWO TOUCHDOWNS AND 100 YARDS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU COLIN COREY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
GREAT BET TO BOTH OF US.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> AND YEAH, I MEAN, THEY'RE
SAYING CONNER IS THE GUY.
GREG IS THE GUY.
GREG FOR MVP.
CONNER NEVER LETS US DOWN.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU CLEO.
SHOUT OUTT TO YOU.
>> THAT'S A WRAP.
>> EVERYBODY --
>> GETTING HOODIES.
>> EXACTLY.
CONNER FINISHED IT FOR ME.
>> PRETTY GOOD.
PRETTY GOOD.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WAGERS.
CONGRATS TO ALL THE HOODIE
WINNERS AND THE TWO JERSEY
WINNERS.
BR BETTING WILL DM YOU WITHIN 24
HOURS.
KEEP THE VIDEOS COMING.
CHASE HOWARD, GRANT, JAKE THE
SNAKE.
WE GOT A LOT OF GOOD VIDEOS THIS
WEEK.
ENJOY YOUR FOOTBALL SUNDAY,
EVERYBODY.
DROP YOUR REALTIME TAKES IN THE
SPORTS BETTING COMMUNITY STREAM
IN THE BLEACHER REPORT APP WHERE
YOU'RE WATCHING US NOW.
FOLLOW US --
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, I'M SORRY,
BROTHER.
I WAS GOING TO LET YOU KEEP
GOING.
>> WHO STAYED AROUND?
>> I PROMISE I WAS GOING TO LET
YOU KEEP GOING BUT I SAW
SOMETHING ABOUT CAM NEWTON.
HERE WE GO.
GREG IS SOLID.
GET CAM TO HAVE THREE OR MORE
TOTE ELO
AL TOUCHDOWNS.
I LIKE THAT.
MY BOY CAM GNNEWTON WAS DOING A
LOT OF YELLING.
THEY ENDED UP LOSING.
HE WAS YELLING FOR NO REASON.
I LIKE THE ENERGY.
GET IN THE END ZONE AND SHOUTOUT
TO ROB.
THANKS FOR STICKING AROUND
BECAUSE YOU WON A HOODIE.
>> YOU KNOW THE DEAL, YOU STICK
AROUND YOU MAY WIN A HOODIE.
I'M CONNER ROGERS FOR GREG, SEE
YOU NEXT WEEK, SAME TIME, SAME
PLACE.